it's March 20th 2020 I'm Justine
and this is my eighth day of quarantine
rhyming was unintentional
this is my dog Maddie and it's also the
first official day that Los Angeles has
shut down and it's my birthday we're
shut down
the walks outside and exercise it's
allowed as long as you're staying six
feet away from others social distancing
respectable ratio so I'm being a little
dramatic with the music and the
voiceover because right now this is what
I normally would be doing it's 5:30 a.m.
I'm making some coffee
and one of the things that we have to
celebrate today other than my birthday
is the fact that Animal Crossing is out
I got up super early today because
there's a video that is due to post
around 5:30 a.m. and I haven't finished
editing it yet you guys can't see it
because it is behind the scenes but
right now I'm shooting this all on my
iPhone I'm doing a fun little test to
see if I can shoot edit do all of the
voiceovers and everything on iOS and of
course stay tuned for a video of that
later on but for now enjoy my super
dramatic moody vlog don't worry the
whole video isn't gonna be like this but
I guess I'm trying to give you a sense
of how I'm feeling I'm feeling strange
I'm feeling weird I'm feeling off and I
think however you guys are feeling right
now
it's completely about I do work with my
friend Tyler who shoots a lot of my
videos for me and edits so he got a jump
start on this edit last night and while
he was doing that I started playing
Animal Crossing because it officially
came out last night March 19th today is
March 20th so he just sent me the XML
file of the footage that he was editing
sent me that I just imported it onto my
computer and now I'm gonna finish the
edit adding some music doing some color
correction
or will we edit for a few hours until
the dog decides that he's ready for a
walk
the weirdest thing is the feeling of
going outside
do you want to go for a walk
[Music]
and hey who's a good boy you
hey did you know Maddie that this leash
is about six feet and that's how far
away we have to be for social distancing
are you listening to me do you care
[Music]
and breakfast is made I'm such a huge
again without Brahma oven I'm gonna be
doing a video with them it's gonna be a
what I eat in a day so it's basically
everything that I cook in there it's
really been amazing because before I got
this oven I never cooked anything and
you guys know this I've been wanting to
do a video on that for a while so now
I'm gonna eat are you a good boy yes you
are Maddie already had his breakfast he
wants eggs that he can't because he has
an allergy you already had your
breakfast keeping consistent and keeping
active is something that I'm really
trying to do one of my suggestions for
you guys is to download the peloton app
I'm sure you guys are very familiar with
peloton with the bike and the treadmill
but peloton actually has this entirely
incredible digital app this is not
sponsored at all I've been such a huge
fan of them check out the app they're
all kinds of really great yoga classes
strength classes meditation it's really
really awesome so especially for a time
like this and the fact that it's free
for 90 days the perfect time to check it
out how are you doing bud I went to buy
some more of these gym mats but I wanted
to extend it a little bit more and
they're all sold out do you know why
because everybody is trying to earn our
home now
[Music]
30 minute intermediate the other flood
class if you're employed lower to
chaturanga or the floor and then come to
your backbend whether it's an up dog or
Cobra and lunges to the hand
[Music]
well I've barely made it through this
today I've heard tired I only slept for
like three hours last night because I
got up so early to start editing but I
cannot stress how incredible this
peloton app is I've been using it for
the past year and I'm definitely lucky
enough to have one of the treadmills but
I travel so much that I probably use the
digital app more than the action will
treadmill in my house it's really great
because you can also do outside runs and
a lot of times you just need bodyweight
for some of those strength classes go
for a walk I'm actually having probably
I would say it's like the best birthday
ever but I'm having a pretty great one
I've had so many incredible birthday
wishes and I even got a few flower
deliveries and I got a cake delivered
today so all things considered it's been
really fun so far and it's been really
nice going out for some walks with Maddy
it's a little really cool seeing
everybody else out walking their dogs go
to our neighbors was like man it's crazy
some of these dogs I better still
excited to have all of their owners home
for so long
definitely drew oh my gosh he's so
excited you might recognize this cake
it's the birthday cake that is into the
animal crossing game this is so
cool exactly like it hi Jesse here's the
thing I could eat this okay myself I
don't know any medicine whatever will I
do the hospitals are overloaded yep
rocket wish me back happy birthday don't
ask my age Jana hi so this is day two of
the lockdown this is actually the first
time that I've really been outside
outside so what this really means
especially for us is they say that you
can go outside you can hike and do
exercises but you have to stay at least
6 feet away from people
there was another hike that we wanted to
do but it's way it's very narrow so this
one Jenna suggested because there's a
lot of wide-open spaces
I think you're safe you're so far away I
can use the measure app this is about
six feet here
I gotta keep going gotta keep coming all
the time I've been doing those Hill runs
on the peloton it sucks
oh so nice out definitely something that
I've taken for granted
[Music]
practicing perfect sort of distancing
they are like exactly six feet apart
it's your breasts they keep you telling
you family so they probably been around
each other but yeah still doing
practicing okay let's practice I'm a
little farther but it's Jana just said
she wants to pick this weed so that she
can sell it hey Josh shake this tree for
me Jana is on her way to my Island it's
giving me her flight information it's a
starting descent are you flying in show
me yeah there you are oh my gosh I'm
having the best time we can be doing the
same thing if we work next to each other
but do you like my hat it's really good
right here I know I'm sorry I should
have came to yours but I have a pole
vault for you and I also have a shovel I
keep talking to him I think that's call
over he doesn't wanna wake up he's
hammered yeah hahaha
Jonah's giving me cherries I'm gonna
give her a shovel and a steak okay did
you get the goods yeah you're gonna be
hyped about that
[Music]
we're doing a sanitized Jana's ah
placing a post mates order for our
dinner a birthday dinner celebration uh
Lathon I'm cleaning this kitchen
it needs a scrub all the Animal Crossing
amiibo to come to my birthday party
or maybe should I just have all the
amiibo at my party what do you think
okay hey Missy how's your birthday party
going gosh this is way over the 10
people limit don't worry I'm making some
eyebrows a slider eyebrows those are big
oh yeah I guess that isn't style man I
just move the cake
[Music]
you don't look very good what is happen
and this is our after
[Music]
incredibly professional the flight from
this angle he actually looks like him he
doesn't see a slider get me drink you
thirsty after a performance he had the
23 time for dinner
Jenna thank you so much Wow a white
vanilla cake with strawberry icing it's
pretty piece that's a huge piece oh that
looks beautiful that looks absolutely
incredible
but why what am I supposed to take that
ball oh I'm so happy
I was editing and I just realized I
didn't shoot an end to this video
because I basically ate the cake and
then played Animal Crossing for the rest
of the night so that's what I did I had
a really great birthday so thank you to
Jenna and thank you didn't intend no for
getting me a cake and thank you to all
of you guys for sending me so many
incredible well wishes it was actually a
very strange time to be sort of
celebrating but I did have a really
great time all things considered
hope you guys are staying safe inside
and I will see you in my next video
[Music]